may have noticed more older cars on the
road as people hold on to their vehicles
longer well this is an effect of the
pandemic as the prices of used cars has
gone up as has the cost to maintain them
also increasing Joshua piguerra looks
into what's driving that Spike
advice from mechanics if you want your
vehicle to last keeping up on your
mileage on your maintenance also rotate
your tires regularly a lot of vehicles
that just have a lot of abuse over time
a lot of neglected maintenance is pretty
much a lot of what we're seeing some
drivers have been listening a bit too
well the average age of a vehicle that's
on the road is 12 years old as people
hold on to their cars much longer repair
shops are having a harder time finding
some of their parts and they're even
having to search even further and wider
than before Alex Vallejo is a Precision
Tune Auto Care says manufacturers are no
longer sending parts in the set instead
they are separate we're seeing that
shrink inflation in a way where they're
taking things away but they're still
charging us and you guys the same cost
according to the Bureau of Labor
Statistics labor in this industry is
rising at a faster rate than inflation
Mark Amazon of AAA Auto Care says
they've increased a hundred to 140
dollars per hour in comparison to last
year for car repairs older vehicles are
harder to work on uh they come with more
problems sometimes uh working on an
older vehicle could lead to more parts
being replaced Amazon ads to research if
you plan to buy a new vehicle a lot of
vehicles are made with plastic
components where they don't tend to hold
too well in the desert heat
according to Kelly Blue Book the average
price of buying a vehicle has gone up by
60 percent in the past decade newer
vehicles on average now cost nearly
fifty thousand dollars where an average
pre-owned go for about 28 000 Christian